hello and welcome to another episode of
what in the world this is a regular show
where Enterprise geo Googlers look at
something interesting in the enterprise
products my name is Dylan Thomas I'm a
Maps community manager and joining me
today is Allen Poole hello hi Allen will
helps customers get products deployed in
production and so what we want to talk
with Allen about today was sort of the
second installment of Google Maps engine
connectors so in our last episode we
talked to Jared Gandhi about the QGIS
connector he'd written to allow the QGIS
desktop product to connect with Google
Maps engine for use there and what
Allen's done is actually take that exact
same concept and applied it to ArcGIS
there's a commercial desktop GIS product
so can you just tell us briefly before
we look at the demo what the impetus was
behind that sure we developed these
connectors for QGIS in our chase desktop
to to make it very simple to sign in if
you are a Google user as well as find a
map and view it inside of these desktop
tools so we want it to be dead simple
for a end user to view their published
Google Maps engine maps in the primary
reason for building these connectors is
to allow the desktop tools to securely
talk with Google Cloud and allow you to
sign in with your credentials so the
Google Maps engine connector for our
chest desktop is available for free and
it is available to anyone on the
arcgis.com gallery so if you go to our
chest comm and you search for Google
Maps engine connector and you click on
tools and you show ArcGIS desktop
content our tools will show up as well
so the Google Maps engine connector for
our chest desktop will show in the
search results and it's as simple as
clicking the open link to download it
and install it in your architecture
so for any ArcGIS desktop user this is
just the no-brainer this is how they do
it there's no special no special thing
going on there no special thing going on
with these tools it's built using the
the ESRI add-in framework so these are
just like any other add-in that you
would add to arcmap so I'm going to
launch arcmap arcum app to open arcmap
10.2 and we'll give it a few seconds to
load okay so this is a standard arcmap
and what you see is the Google Maps
engine connector for Rjay for arcmap
tool bar that is available and if you
don't see the toolbar you can right
click on on the tool area and it's
available to turn on if you don't see it
and you'll note that the the arc that
the toolbar that's available none of the
buttons are enabled by default so the
first step with the connector for arcmap
is you need to sign in with your google
account in any google account will work
so the first button lets you sign in or
sign out of your Google account so I'm
going to click the sign in button and
since I've already signed in with my
demonstration account my name is
remembered but you could sign in with
some gmail account or some Google Apps
account as well so I'm going to sign in
and authenticate with my Allen pool at
altostrat comm account the second step
is you need to authorize the connector
to access your Google Maps engine data
so I'm going to click accept
and you'll note that the find button
becomes active so once you're signed in
you're able to find Google Maps engine
maps in any map any maps engine account
so I'm gonna click on the find button
and the dialog pops up and lets you find
any published map that is available and
these are the same maps that we showed
last week with ujaval in in QGIS they're
also available to view here inside of
our jeaious so I'm going to click on the
earth at night map that he showed last
week and the Archaea connector
communicates with Google Maps engine and
automatically adds a WMS layer of all
the layers inside of your published map
so if you have a Google Maps engine map
with vector data or raster data those
layers are available in one single click
so I'm going to turn on these WMS layers
and you can see this is the world at
night as published by NASA and there is
a secondary layer that's added with kind
of ancillary metadata about your Google
Maps engine map so let me add a Google
Maps engine map that contains vector
data as well
so to do that I'm going to change the
projection of my map to web Mercator to
align with the Google Maps engine
projections and if I go back to the
search dialog I published some census
data as well so there are some census
data for San Francisco so if I add this
census map
and I turn on the census WMS layers
you'll see that in the san francisco
area there is some road data as well as
some con congressional boundaries as
well and you can you can style us this
is sort of something you can style in
Aceh as to some extent right so these
are just standard WMS layers of the
pre-styled and pre styled by the map
publisher inside of maps engine the the
connectors work with both you know
raster layers and vector layers and if
you have Google Maps engine maps with
one too many layers that were just fine
as well so let me demonstrate the next
piece of functionality in the map so
that's all searched in kind of
visualization of your Maps but if I have
some local data that I want to upload
the Google Maps engine connector allows
you to do that as well so I'm gonna add
a raster layer and a shape file that's
locally available in my repository but
this would work if you had an enterprise
geo database like an Oracle spatial or
file geodatabase all that would work as
well so it's basically anything that the
ArcGIS recognizes as a as a feature
class layer or raster layer is gonna be
faking to upload exactly any native
format that is supported by arcmap and
if you add a layer you'll note that the
interact button becomes active and you
can actually interactively upload this
data to your arcmap or to your Google
Maps engine account so I'm gonna select
the kind of earth TIFF image that I've
added to my arcmap and you'll note that
the upload button becomes active so I'm
going to click on upload to Google Maps
engine which will pop up a dialog and
you're asked to fill in a couple of
attributes about this upload before you
do so so the first step is to select a
Google Maps engine account do you have
access to
I'm gonna click on altostrat demo I'm
gonna go you have to name this asset so
I'm gonna call it WSI earth I give it a
description TIFF image of the entire
world
and give it a tag so earth image and
then the next two are required and they
have to exist first so you need to have
an access list that you're going to
upload this to so I'm going to call this
connector editors and give it an
attribution which we'll call it ESRI so
the connector editors are the group of
people that will have access to this
image once it's uploaded so I'm gonna
click on the upload files button mm-hmm
and the the Google Maps engine connector
for our GS desktop is asking arcmap to
convert this file to a standard format
that can be uploaded to the Google Maps
engine API so if it's in some strange
file format that arcmap understands we
we will ask arcmap to convert it to
something that is supported and once
it's converted we'll upload those files
to arcmap or to your Google Maps engine
account that's what's happening right
now this is using so in terms of the API
we did a little bit of the metadata work
prep preparation to fill out your form
now you're doing a post using basically
a five the new file upload or asset
creation endpoint exactly yep so the
first step was just to request through
the Maps engine API a new asset and then
posting each file to the Maps engine API
and the last step is it opens it up in
the map publishers interface inside of
Google Maps engine you can see it's
already starting to process for the map
editor I think that sort of rounded out
the workflow that we wanted to share I
which is just simple access through an
authorized or authenticated connection
Roth and the second one is being able to
actually push data into Maps engine then
sort of as you said publish once view
anyway
the the second interesting thing we just
want to cover briefly I guess is that
this is I in fact an open-source project
just like the hugest one is and I was
written by yourself up to this point I
was wondering if you could tell us a
little bit about that
you know are you accepting pull requests
how do you see this growing from hand
yep so there are the the Google Maps
engine code for the Arkham a proportion
is written in microsoft.net c-sharp
which we think is very important for a
lot of GIS professionals so the code is
on the Google Maps github repository so
any person can take this code as
reference or take this code and add to
it we are accepting contributions but
we'll take them closely it was kind of
guarded and we'll add them to the kind
of Google controlled compiled version
that's on arcgis.com
so anyone is welcome to participate in
the open-source project and if you're
you know suggestions are worth good you
know worth putting into the the Google
compiled version we're willing to do
that as well so the just that the the
version that someone anyone would
download with no knowledge of the code
no knowledge of the API they just want
to download it to work with maps inch
and that's gonna be something that we
will build compile and make sure is on
our GS calm all right and if anyone
wants to add to that we'll consider it
if anyone wants to fork this please go
ahead learn from it absolutely improve
and if anyone's developing in c-sharp
this is a good reference case for how
you would implement the Aria wolf to the
oauth2 or file upload or Google Maps
engine API functionality great Allen
thanks for taking the time to show this
to us that it's really exciting I'm glad
we've got to the commercial side of this
and also the open-source side on the
QGIS so thanks very much and I think
that's it for what in the world we'll
see you next time